Mount jarrow is being called The Miracle
Solution to losing stubborn fat and has
been used in type 2 diabetes patients
now joining us today to tell us more is
America's favorite doctor Dr Laura Purdy
welcome to the show hi great to have you
here so we're talking off here what is
Mount jarrow what am I saying it right I
think so I spent a lot of time looking
into how to say it right away and I
think you are but it's a new so
technically it's a diabetes medication
right but a lot of people are taking it
for weight loss it's an injection that
you take once a week okay and it's it is
mind-blowing astronomical unprecedented
weight loss okay there's some big words
there describing it how much weight loss
are we seeing in patients uh so I have a
ton of patients that are taking it and
it hasn't been out for very long okay so
we don't have a lot of people that are
at the long-term maintenance dose like
you would after several months of being
on it but sometimes I see 25 30 pounds a
month wow can anyone use it
just about anyone so there's a few
there's a few reasons why you couldn't
do it so obviously pregnant nursing and
there is an association with people who
have genetic thyroid cancers which is
very rare okay and it's generally one of
those things that if you have it you
know it right so um and it's not good
for those people but just about everyone
else yes so those that are seeing the
results of 25 pounds a month they're
taking the shot or they seeing any side
effects from it sometimes so I will say
that you know again it hasn't been out
for for very long and so from what we
can tell it does seem to be very safe
and very well tolerated in the short and
long term a lot of people do have some
nausea okay but for the vast majority of
people it's it's not as bad as as the
weight that they're losing I'm sure
they're happy to to either power through
it or take some nausea medicine and they
they're doing great and your license in
all 50 states and you prescribe this so
someone's watching we'll give your
website here in a second but they do the
shot are you working out are you
changing your diet do you just do the
shot and sit back and there goes the
weight I mean I think think there's
there's something for everybody right so
I think the ones that have the best like
so my patients do a lot of them come
back and tell me what they're doing and
I think the ones who are doing the very
best are the ones who yes they are
exercising they are like having a
generally um healthier changing your
lifestyle yes but
but they're losing weight too
fine and start the process yeah so I
mean if you want to be my patient you
can find me on push Health you can
request me directly at hey I want to see
Dr Purdy they know who I am and and you
can be my patient Danny will have a
consultation with him right next to jump
right into talk to them that's awesome
absolutely thank you so much doctor for
joining us today we appreciate it thank
you for having me all right Las Vegas
now we will be right back